c'est un hommage en toute sobriété 21
ans après le meurtre de christelle
blétry l'émotion est toujours présente
d'autant que dans quelques mois le
meurtrier présumé de la jeune femme sera
à nouveau jugée à dijon devant la cour
d'appel d'assises une épreuve
supplémentaire pour la mère de
christelle blétry je pense pas trop pour
le moment
est ce que je sais que ça va être
difficile donc bon j'ai pris l'habitude
maintenant de vivre les événements au
jour le jour et je me prépare pas 3 ça
pas pour le moment
marie-rose bletterie peut compter sur le
soutien des membres de l'association
christelle qui vient en aide aux
familles de victimes d'agression
criminelle car au delà de la douleur
il y à de nombreux dommages collatéraux
marie pichon s'est elle aussi battue
pendant des années pour retrouver le
meurtrier de sa fille
et c'est toute sa vie familiale qui a
été bouleversé
j'ai lutté un peu plus mal à dire sinon
même je pense que supporteront pas eu
une autre vie vaut le plus faire noël
peut rien faire plus faire la fête ça
revient petit à petit moi ça va faire
trempette comment ça c'est dur de telle
affaire engendre également des frais qui
ne sont pas remboursés et l'association
christelle vient actuellement en aide à
onze familles
ces six dernières années il a fallu
débourser au total plus de 90000 euros
dans tous vos tribunal pour une affaire
il faut savoir si vous voulez que si le
procès fait sur neuf jours il ya
uniquement que le premier jour en dix
ans de présence et le jour où la famille
plaide à séoul et qui sont payés les
sept autres sources ont perdu donc si
vous voulez l'employeur lui ne paye pas
et en contrepartie si vous les deux
le tribunal ne prend pas en charge
chaque année l'association christelle
organise une quinzaine d'événements pour
récolter des fonds
de l'argent qui permet aux familles de
victimes d'assister au procès